[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un amoureux de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
rugby la fédération française à l'issue
de son bureau fédéral a annoncé l'arrêt
des saisons amateurs 2020 2021 en raison
de la situation sanitaire en france
c'est un calendrier impossible à tenir
nous recevrons dans ce magazine et club
de versailles et de plaisir golf
le nouveau président de la fédération
française pascal grizot sera avec nous
dans quelques instants
il reviendra sur les différents sujets
yvelinois nous parlerons notamment de
l'open de france et des jo de 2024
interview dans quelques instants
automobile coup de projecteur sur un
binôme yvelinois juliette axel vont
participer à un rallye 100% électrique
et 100% féminin le départ est programmé
début mai reportage à suivre l'actualité
sportive c'est maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres on
va parler un football le championnat de
nationale 2 ne reprendra finalement pas
dans l'immédiat acté le 18 février
dernier avec un protocole strict la
reprise est décalée à une date
ultérieure vu la situation sanitaire
actuelle c'est le ministère des sports
qui a annoncé cette information dans les
yvelines les clubs de poissy de
versailles ne reprendront donc pas le
chemin du rectangle vert joueurs peuvent
tout de même s'entraîner ils attendent
désormais une nouvelle date pour la
reprise du championnat
on va maintenant parler rugby est la
décision est tombée la fédération
française à l'issue de son bureau
fédéral a annoncé l'arrêt des saisons
amateurs 2020 2021 en raison de la
situation à sanitaire en france est un
calendrier impossible à tenir
la ffr a notamment a décidé de figer les
montées et léa décente pour tous les
niveaux sauf dérogation obtenue du
ministère en charge des sports ce sera
donc une à saison blanche pour tous les
clubs libinois pour nous parler de cette
décision nous avons avec nous en plateau
sébastien roncalli directeur sportif de
plaisir soir bonsoir
et nous avons avec nous en visio éric
tournier président du rugby-club de
versailles
bonsoir bonsoir alors comment avez vous
réagi à cette décision
sébastien déjà nous on a forcément été
très déçu puisqu'on avait fait un très
très bon début de saison
donc forcément très frustré de l'arrêt
vont maintenant à valence et attendait
forcément puisque nous on a eu la chance
de réaliser nos six matches mais il y
avait des équipes qui en avait fait que
quatre war 3 donc on savait que les
problématiques étaient déjà lancés début
de saison donc on s'attendait
effectivement un arrière qui s'est
confirmée au bout de six matchs éric
tournier votre réaction
c'est un peu la même chose à versailles
très déçus parce que nous voulions
laisser cimade et on était sur des
pommes des bons résultats puisque ans a
été premier de poule mais en même temps
pas du tout surpris parce que
effectivement on s'y attendait avec ses
contraintes sanitaires et on dit calais
ont décalé tout le temps la reprise donc
bon c'est irréaliste de tanus les
malheureuses pour une saison blanche
est-ce qu'en septembre vous aviez
imaginé cette situation eric tournier
non bien sûr que non puisque on avait
fait en sorte de t'avoir côté on avait
mis en place tout un système au club
avec des perspectives et objectifs on
avait des nouveaux partenaires on était
vraiment dans un dans un objectif d'une
saison pleine abouti puisque on en
sortait d'une demi saison donc on
espérait on espérait vraiment pouvoir
faire
voilà une saison complète
malheureusement assez vite interrompue
j'ai bien dommage maintenant on pense
déjà à l'avenir
les clubs ont été consultés ou pas du
tout sébastien ans cali dans cette
décision non pas du tout non j'ai déçu
justement de ne pas avoir été peut être
questionné là dessus non je pense que
effectivement là la décision nous nous
appartenait pas je pense que c'était
obligatoire d'en arriver à cette
extrémité parce que façon c'était
impossible de continuer déjà trop de
décalage en termes de matches c'est
normal que ça arrive comme ça
certains parlent et de peut-être de
saison peut être transformé hybride avec
une fin de saison un peu plus tardive
oui elle fait souvent usage abl il ya eu
des propositions de pas mal
d'entraîneurs de pas mal de clubs
effectivement des propositions qui qui
était envisageable mais bon après un
moment donné là il ya la coupure est
tellement longue vie
il ya une grosse partie de ses
utilisations à faire au niveau des gars
donc bon faut être cohérent oscillent en
arriver à un moment où j'ai frotte rdif
en termes de planning pour pouvoir caler
un championnat et puis moi ou faire un
chalenge eu des choses comme ça bon je
vois pas trop l'intérêt
c'était dangereux peut-être éric
tournier peut-être de reprendre le
championnat
on en parlait à l'instant la priorité
après d'azur le les conditions
sanitaires c'est la sécurité des joueurs
impossible de pouvoir reprendre sur la
calendrier standard le rugby il fallait
au minimum un mois et demi drop physique
donc c'est le calendrier pourrait pas
tenir dividendes ou non c'est une
malheureusement les déçus mais
heureusement que cette décision a été
prise alors maintenant on nous propose
effectivement éventuellement des petits
tournois par ci par là mais ni les
compétiteurs amateurs ce qui va les
joueurs gênés couler c'était faire
surtout de championnat de france chaque
fin de saison ça qui les motive
là il n'y a plus vraiment d'intérêt donc
non nous clairement on se projette sur
sur la semaine prochaine dans quel état
d'esprit justement sont les joueurs
sébastien en caddie est ce que vous avez
senti les des hommes abattus peut-être
chez vous un plaisir ah oui dans
l'ensemble oui on a on a on a du mal à
les faire venir au stade jean le
président de versailles a pas d'objectif
donc c'est très très compliqué de les
motiver
même si on a la chance par rapport à
d'autres clubs par rapport à d'autres
sports pardon de pouvoir pratiquer avec
un un protocole restreint mais on peut
quand même pratiqué mais malgré sa non
c'est très compliqué de le faire venir
est-ce qu'on peut perdre certains
joueurs peut être des bons joueurs on
sait que les yvelines ce sont un peu des
unitaires de deux formations avec des
jeunes joueurs là ils jouent pas
finalement depuis un voire deux ans est
ce que ce sera compliqué de l'est
les mettre à niveau moi je pense qu'il
est possible qu'on a un peu de perdition
effectivement est d'ailleurs là c'est un
sujet sur lequel on se colle a appelé à
relancer tous les mecs parce
qu'effectivement un peu inquiet sur le
sujet j'aimerais vous attendait une
baisse du nombre de licenciés au club
moi j'ai un peu peur de ça effectivement
bah allez les mecs ont passé du temps un
peu à faire autre chose donc
on se posait aussi des questions et
peuvent choisir de faire autre chose
pour le futur a effectivement président
en terme de sponsoring est ce que c'est
c'est grave également peut-être pour le
rugby amateur
oui je pense qu'en fait on va avoir les
conséquences à cette saison dès la
saison prochaine
là les partenaires ont maintenu leur
promesse de septembre on les a cette
saison mais il est bien évident que moi
j'ai déjà des retours en disant on n'a
pas dit et je passe rien cette année
donc il va y aura un impact sur la
saison prochaine j'en suis sûr
malheureusement certains clubs enfermé
peut-être n'est pas la visibilité des
mois j'ai eu récemment au téléphone le
président de la ligue de france qui me
disait un peu la même chose c'est à dire
que sur cette saison les clubs s'en tire
plutôt bien parce que on a très peu de
dépenses sur les plus vision donc on a
des partenaires ils sont soutenus dans
cette période dont pour la saison qui
arrive sera cette fin de saison je veux
dire je pense que les clubs
financièrement vont passer le cap
par contre pour la saison prochaine ça
va être effectivement compliqué est ce
que vous préparez déjà là la saison
prochaine sébastien ans cali on veut
tout à fait vrai déjà le mercato déjà
élancé ouais ouais ouais déjà oui il ya
des projets c'est ça qui vont se mettre
en place et à leurs nouveaux clubs là on
parle effectivement on en a profité pour
travailler sur un projet de son
entraînement labellisé alors voilà donc
qui va être présentée très prochainement
à la mairie et on l'espère à la région
est en tout cas dès septembre 2021 là
pour cette année on en ouvrira des
académies oui pour renforcer notre
formation et pouvoir proposer aux jeunes
une formation de qualité au club
même question pour vous est ce que vous
préparez déjà la saison prochaine éric
tournier
vous de nous on apparaître janvier parce
que depuis janvier on envisageait
vraiment cette malheureusement cette fin
de saison
donc là on a on a bien avancé sur
effectivement les seniors on pense non
plus renoue favril normes hautement et
puis et puis pour les autres catégories
bon voilà on a 90 % de présence donc
tout va bien on s'inquiète un peu pour
les juniors mais voilà on met en place
également a suivi régulier les
entraînements sont toujours là toutes
les catégories
donc je pense qu'on n'aura pas trop nous
de perte de licenciés
donc on se concentre vraiment maintenant
sur sur la saison prochaine tous les
niveaux et pour l'instant tous les feux
sont des adversaires
merci à tous les deux d'être intervenu
dans cette émission pour parler de cet
arrêt des championnats amateurs de rugby
rendez vous donc en ces temps où l'on
espère cette fois ci que la saison ira à
son terme bon courage à vous et puis
comment ça ne veut pas ça ne veut pas le
national golf le oui qui devait se
dérouler du 1er au 3 avril sur le golf
national de saint quentin en libye a été
officiellement décalé à l'année
prochaine l'événement devait accueillir
les golfeurs français un salon avec des
produits du golfe ainsi que des
démonstrations un rendez-vous soutenue
par la fédération française de golf pour
promouvoir ce sport en france on écoute
l'un des organisateurs charles-henri
bachelet c'est une grande tristesse car
une événement s'annonçait sous les
meilleurs auspices il y avait une
adhésion absolument incroyable des
professionnels et des passionnés
donc évidemment ça fait pas plaisir mais
à un moment il faut se confronter au
principe de réalité d'accepter voilà
c'était impossible au vu des conditions
sanitaires de pouvoir tenir l'événement
et donc il n'était absolument pas
responsables de vouloir rassembler la
population qu'elle est drainée cet
événement on continue à parler golf avec
un invité exceptionnel le nouveau
président de la fédération française de
golf pascal grizot est avec nous dans
cette émission via
craon interposés bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous avez 58 ans vous avez été élu en
décembre dernier pour quatre années
vos premiers mois on commet de la
fédération ont-ils été intense bah oui
ils ont été intenses parce qu'on a une
actualité aussi qui est intense
on a enfin je crois que c'était le jour
où j'ai été élu ou quelques jours après
le european tour avait décidé de ne pas
programmer l'open de france au
calendrier donc il a fallu un mois
d'intenses négociations ensuite on a
créé cette alliance
vous savez que nous avons écrit au
président de la république et au premier
ministre pour leur grande et les
avantages des sports de plein air dont
évidemment le golf c'est parti on a
décidé de se regrouper avec plusieurs
autres fédérations notamment la
fédération de l'équitation la fédération
de la pêche delà de la voile de la
chasse également donc à cinq fédérations
nous avons écrit au président de la
république pour lui demander que
malheureusement s'il devait procéder à
un nouveau confinement d'épargner les
sports de plein air parce que c'est
avant tout une filière économique mais
aussi la possibilité pour tous les
françaises de continuer à pratiquer un
sport de plein air pour lequel il n'y a
pas de risques vis-à-vis de face au co
vide on n'est pas tous égaux face au co
vide et face au risque du coc vides et
les sports de plein air en tout cas son
une soupape d'oxygène qu'il est permis
de donner aux français pour continuer à
pratiquer leur sport et leurs loisirs
dont le comique entre l'open de france
entre la création de l'alliance de
nombreux autres sujets et bien oui l
actualité chargée
vous travaillez déjà sur l'après
qu'ovide 19 oui on travaille d'abord
même si on peut reprendre
comme lors du premier confinement sion
pour aujourd'hui on a la possibilité de
pratiquer notre sport mais pas encore
les compétitions or les golfeurs sont
très attachés à leur compétition qui
sont plus des animations de loisirs
plutôt que des compétitions au strict
terme au strict aussi au sens strict du
terme pardon bien sûr quand on parle de
compétitions sportives on évoque souvent
ces grands rassemblements que sont les
compétitions notamment les compétitions
de sports collectifs au golf les
compétitions amateurs sont de toute
façon des compétitions qui se joue à
huit clos donc pas de spectateurs et les
risques face au co vite sont extrêmement
limités donc ce qu'on demande à notre
ministère de tutelle mais également au
premier ministre c'est de nous accorder
la possibilité de reprendre ces
compétitions amateurs qui sont des
animations sportives pour lesquels il
n'y a pas de brassage puisque
aujourd'hui pas de brassage
supplémentaire puisque aujourd'hui rien
ne m'empêche d'aller jouer dans le sud
de la france pour faire une partie
amicale
or quand on fait des compétitions on
s'aperçoit que notamment grâce à
l'organisation et au protocole syndical
cne en place la fédération nous avons la
possibilité de mettre des arbitres à
disposition qui veut sont là pour
veiller de la bonne application du
protocole sanitaire donc j'ai envie de
dire que lorsque l'on fait des
compétitions de bol on n'est plus
protégé pour tromper ses compétences et
c'est cette partie loisirs du week-end
donc on m'a demandé à notre ministère de
bien vouloir me laisser reprendre ces
compétitions qui sont des animations
qu'attendent tous les golfeurs
passionnés on va maintenant parler à des
différents dossiers qui concernent les
yvelines on avait un petit peu plus tôt
dans cette émission la national golf le
wiki est reportée à 2022 toujours au
golf national de saint-quentin divine
c'est une décision logique selon vous
c'est une compétition décision logique
qui a été prise en totale collaboration
avec la préfecture et les organisateurs
charles-henri bacheliers pour pouvoir
avoir des positions prescrit comme
celles que j'ai pu avoir tout à l'heure
en vous parlant de la reprise des
compétitions sportives
il faut être aussi extrêmement prudent
et aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si le fait
d'avoir 5 mai
groupement de 5000 personnes même si la
majorité de la nationale bob quick se
passent en extérieur mais en tout cas un
regroupement de plus de 5000 personnes
par jour est-ce que c'est raisonnable ou
pas en tout cas quand on a un doute on
préfère ne pas prendre de décisions qui
pourraient mettre en danger les
personnels qui participeront à cette
tâche et d'un bol quick où les golfeurs
qui souhaiteraient se déplacer au golf
national donc la décision que nous avons
pris c'est la décision du bon sens et la
décision de la sécurité vis-à-vis de
tous les publics qui pourraient se
retrouver dans cette tâche à un autre
dossier concerne les yves hinse et celui
de l'open de france de golf 1 qui sont
organisées du 6 au 9 mai au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
vous êtes satisfait sur ces dates
bah écoute et wii est d'abord on est
satisfait que cet open soit de nouveau
programmé ça aurait été vécue comme une
véritable injustice puisque de nombreux
sauf d'open se déroule sur le continent
européen
quelles que soient les conditions
sanitaires puisque aujourd'hui en tout
cas en france les compétitions
professionnelles peuvent être joués à
condition qu'elle puisse est joué et
bibelots et aux bottes nationale
il était parfaitement possible organiser
un open de france qui soit lui aussi à 8
mo j'espère que la situation évoluera et
que on pourrait éventuellement accepter
des spectateurs mais pour l'instant en
tout cas la position du ministère des
sports et celle de ne pas de pouvoir
organiser l'open de france mais de ne
pas par contre pouvoir accepter de
public ça nous va très bien parce que
tout le monde peut comprendre que des
contraintes liées à cette pandémie due
qu'aux villes mais par contre les
licenciés et n'aurait pas accepté qu'il
ne puisse pas y avoir un open de france
programmés ou obl passionnel donc oui je
suis très heureux que cette un peu notre
open puisse de nouveau trouver une date
la dotation ne sera pas énorme en 1.5
millions d'euros environ
est ce que c'est une
déception c'est faute de sponsors c'est
ça non c'est pas faute de sponsors parce
que le european tour qui a la charge de
l'organisation et la responsabilité de
l'organisation en tant que promoteur
s'est engagé lui à mettre à disposition
des joueurs cette dotation de 1 million
et demi et un million et demi c'est la
moyenne des dotations que vous retrouvez
sur la totalité du cette année pour
toutes les compétitions d'europe
continentale
mise à part les rolex séries donc là la
dotation est inférieur aux autres années
mais elle est tout à fait en ligne avec
les dotations des autres open dans les
autres pays
malheureusement suite suite au kobe est
ce que vous avez espoir que cette
dotation augmente dans les prochaines
années
alors oui elle augmentera parce qu on
est en train de travailler avec
l'european tour
mais aussi le pitié tour donc en or et
aux états unis
les deux grands organisateurs de
compétitions internationales et on est
en train de travailler avec eux sur le
concept d'un tournoi il serait beaucoup
plus richement au dp puisqu'on
avoisinerait les 10 millions de dollars
mais en contrepartie on a une garantie
du champ de joueurs ou un peu comme dans
un w j'essaie donc en tournoi mondial
on a la certitude d'avoir 60 et 70
meilleurs joueurs du monde il y à un
autre dossier qui qui nous intéresse
également dans les yvelines c'est celui
des championnats du monde amateurs qui
se dérouleront en 2022 et les jeux
olympiques en 2024 également est ce que
ce sont deux événements sur lesquels
vous comptez beaucoup la fédération
française de golf
oui parce que d'abord c'est une chance
de pouvoir recevoir des tournois de
cette qualité on a d'abord en 2022 les
championnats du monde amateurs
garçons comme pour les filles qui se
dérouleront sur deux parcours des
yvelines puisque une épreuve se
déroulera les 6 vous les championnats du
monde il ya tellement de joueurs le
chant est tellement important qu'il faut
deux parcours pour pouvoir organiser ces
championnats du monde donc les garçons
et les filles joueront sur deux parcours
différents qui seront le parcours du
golf national bien évidemment mais aussi
le parcours de saint nom la bretèche qui
a lui aussi accueilli de très grands
tournois comme le trophée lancôme ou
comme le pi lundi trophy et les membres
de sa dans la bretèche et j'en remercie
nous ont mis à disposition leur parcours
pour que et bien le parcours de saint
nom la bretèche fasse partie de la
rotation de ses deux parcours des
championnats du monde et c'est
évidemment extrêmement important parce
que très souvent les championnats du
monde sont l'antichambre de la golf
professionnel et vous retrouver dans ces
championnats du monde amateurs les
futurs meilleurs joueurs du monde ça a
été le cas pour les espagnols avec john
rahway jordan spis aussi à jouer ce
tournoi
tous les meilleurs joueurs du monde qui
performent aujourd'hui sur les circuits
professionnels ont joué ces championnats
du monde donc c'est une grande chance
pour la france de pouvoir accueillir ces
championnats du monde et jeux olympiques
peuvent attirer peut-être un nouveau
public peut être aussi écouter qu'un
golfeur la ryder cup
on avait fixé une jauge à 55000
spectateurs pensaient qu à l'époque le
organisateurs le co organisateur avec la
fédération française de golf avait
décidé de limiter le nombre de
spectateurs à 55
on s'est aperçu pour tous ceux qui
étaient présents pendant la ryder cup on
aurait parfaitement pu avoir un plus
grand nombre de spectateurs
et je le dis là pas forcément pour vous
faire plaisir mais c'est parce que c'est
la réalité
la communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines avait fait un
travail remarquable notamment pour nous
aider au niveau du transport et on s'est
aperçu qu'en tout plus vite et on avait
pu accueillir de 55000 spectateurs pour
les jeux olympiques
la jauge une jauge à 30000 spectateurs
qu'on est quasiment certain de pouvoir
remplir
parce que les jeux olympiques
accueillent un public qui est différent
mais aussi un public qui est très
intéressé pour pouvoir suivre ces
époques où les meilleurs joueurs du
monde ont participé
dernière question très rapidement qu'est
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour ces
quatre prochaines années
très rapidement il ya plein de choses à
d'abord n'est pas simplement que pour le
golf que cette endémie s'arrête et qu'on
puisse reprendre le chemin des golfs en
toute sécurité qu'on puisse jouer des
tournois avec des spectateurs puisque
pour l'open de france et même dommage
d'avoir la chance d'accueillir un si
grand tournoi et que les spectateurs ne
puisse pas être autorisé à à se dérouler
donc dans le monde moi ce que je
souhaite c'est que cette pandémie
s'arrête est autrement pour la
fédération française de golf
bien que cet engouement qu'il ya pour
les sports de plein air puis se
continuer d'asseoir la fédération
enregistrent des chiffres qui sont polis
parce que notre nombre de licenciés a
augmenté sur les deux premiers mois par
rapport aux chiffres que nous avions
organisée que nous avions enregistré
l'année dernière qui était les chiffres
records donc il ya un engouement pour
les sports de plein air et j'espère que
et bien voilà la fédération ben profiter
et qu'on aura aussi des joueurs et des
joueuses françaises qu'il conte partie
des meilleurs joueurs et joueuses
mondiales
aujourd'hui on a un garçon qui fait
partie des trentenaires joueur mondial
et victor perez et on a une fille céline
indiqué qu'il fait partie des 61 du
monde j'espère que très rapidement on
aura plus de joueurs et plus de joueuses
qui font partie des 51
merci à vous pascal grizot merci à vous
d'être intervenu dans cette émission je
rappelle les dates du prochain open de
france de golf ils sont organisées du 6
au 9 mai au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
une dernière information golf c'est l'un
des exploits du week end vinoir antoine
ros leur a aussi a remporté ce dimanche
sa deuxième victoire sur le tour
européen au qatar quatre mois après son
succès à dubaï le golfeur de la boulie à
versailles réussi à s'imposer avec un
putt de 20 mètres sur le dernier trou
97e joueur mondial avant le début du
tournoi antoine brothers va devenir 62e
cette semaine le sportif de 28 ans
obtient également sa qualification pour
les as championnat du monde de
match-play à austin aux états unis du 24
au 28 mars
en cyclisme ses fils y avait finalement
maximilian chache man qui remporte le
paris-nice 2021 pour la deuxième année
consécutive l'allemand loin d'être
favori au départ de cette édition le
dimanche 7 mars depuis saint cyr l'école
a réussi à chiper lors de la dernière
étape le maillot jaune duo slovène
primoz sera glitch ce dernier a été
victime d'une chute à 70 km de l'arrivée
le paris-nice passera dans l'est asie
been au minimum jusqu'en 2025 on ne
connaît pas encore les deux villes qui
auront le privilège d'accueillir la
course au soleil l'année à prochaine on
va prendre maintenant la direction de
versailles la ville va accueillir le 9
mars prochain le départ d'un premier
réalise 100 % électrique et 100% féminin
parmi à les participants un équipage
évidement composé de deux collègues va
prendre le départ de cette épreuve
leurs portraits des images de patrick
jacques de dixmude 1-2 yvelinoise se
lancent à l'aventuré juliette 48 ans
originaire de versailles axel 39 ans de
verneuil-sur-seine vont participer au
premier rallye 100% électrique et 100%
féminin le départ sera donné le 9 mai
prochain depuis versailles
un projet inédit qui a séduit les
participantes là c'était vraiment
l'occasion d'avoir un rallye en rupture
un rallye complètement différent où
l'objectif c'est pas un objectif de
vitesse mais c'est vraiment il ya
vraiment une notion
d'environnement et de respect de
l'environnement puisqu'en fait il va
falloir relier un point à point b en
limitant l'énergie consommée au maximum
pour réussir à parcourir l'ensemble des
800 km de cette course d'orientation les
deux aventurières comptent sur leur
complémentarité
elle travaille on sent chez l'entreprise
lilloise vd com spécialisé dans
l'immobilité autonome
c'est une collègue que j'apprécie
beaucoup on est très complémentaires
moi je suis plutôt la communicante elle
s'est plutôt l'ingénieur fans de mecha
et on se dit qu'à nous deux on allait
faire une très belle équipe on est
complémentaires au niveau professionnel
mais aussi au niveau personnel
on a des qualités complémentaires axel
elle est très organisée sont bonnes
gestionnaires
moi je suis plutôt la créative
enthousiaste donc je pense qu'on va bien
s'entendre
cette amitié sera soumise à rude épreuve
pendant ces six jours de compétitions le
trajet se fera uniquement avec une carte
et une boussole sans téléphone ni gps
pendant que les véhicules se
rechargeront les équipages devront
poursuivre leur route à pied dans les
montagnes sur 10 kilomètres chaque jour
un programme qui n'effraie pas les
yvelinoises on espère être dans les
trois meilleurs équipages bien sûr
puisque sont les trois premiers qui
seront récompensés on est douze
équipages et bien sûr va on espère
trouver les balises le plus rapidement
possible puisque l'objectif c'est de
trouver des paniers sur un parcours qui
est tenu secret jusqu'au jusqu'au jour j
l'équipage recherche encore des sponsors
pour pouvoir participer à l'épreuve elle
espère boucler leur budget avant la fin
mars
c'est la fin de cette émission très
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]